all right well
uh happy thursday and a welcome uh
wolfram language
and wolfram technology enthusiasts uh
my name is captain timothy newlin i'm a
captain in the united states army i'm
also an assistant professor
at the united states military academy at
west point new york
where i have the distinct privilege of
being able to
shape and mold future leaders of
character to become lieutenants and
junior officers
in the united states army it's with that
perspective
that i share with you today my talk
about
using wolfram cloud forms in order to
motivate math models
in a remote learning but also a hybrid
learning type
environment and so many of us have found
ourselves in
different situations in terms of the way
that we interact with colleagues whether
that's in the education environment or
in the corporate environment
uh but one of the nice things about
wolfram language and wolfram
technologies particularly
with a lot a lot of the cloud functions
is
the ability to share information uh or
visualize information
for yourself and then be able to convey
that um
through the internet in a means that is
uh effective and also in a way that
uh your students your cadets or um
your work partners colleagues can then
understand what you're trying to
communicate because
we are focused on optimizing for
developing leaders of character who are
good problem solvers
and so while i may have a particular
passion for mathematics that doesn't
mean that all my students do
but i find that if i can tell effective
stories
if i'm an effective storyteller and they
feel like they've been brought into the
story of how i might solve a problem
that is important to me um
that they're a little bit more willing
to stick around for some of the math
and so one of the things that i've used
in order to
try and become a better storyteller is
a lot of the graphics and plots in
wolfram language via mathematica
primarily
all of our students have access to
mathematica
and it's with that understanding that um
in a remote environment yes you could
email
certain notebooks but it's a lot more
effective and productive i think
to either deploy notebooks or to create
forms that then allow
students to manipulate parameters or the
values of certain variables and see what
happens right on the screen in front of
them
so that's what i'm focused on i'm going
to show you a few examples today
my abstract is that many students face
significant challenges
and visualizing concepts that was true
before the remote learning environment
it's all the more true
now that we're sometimes distributed i
should say that
sometimes i'm teaching students in class
with a mask
in a small section socially distanced uh
within the classroom which has its own
um additional challenges but uh some of
the time i'm also
on uh video chats in order to
either convey information after the
class is over
or occasionally some of the concepts
that we use mathematica
or wolfram language and other software
products to assist in visualization
may be taught entirely remotely but all
west point cadets are required to
take a course that uses math models in
order to apply their problem solving
skills
to real-world situations and we focus on
being able to take the real world
transform it into some sort of
mathematical model
that then we can solve and often the
tool for solving is wolfram language
usually through mathematica and then
take that solution
that math solution and interpret it for
a decision maker
and what we found is that a lot of times
students
grasp or jump at the chance to be able
to use
technology in order to solve something
that they would have had to have done
hand computation board before and the
better that we can utilize that
technology in order to solve
problems the more time that we get to
spend interpreting the results
which is uh where a lot of the value
comes in terms of being able to
affect decision makers in terms of
understand helping them understand
what's going on with a particular
situation
and so i'm going to show several
different wolfram forms that i created
uh to help assist my cadets my students
who are mostly college freshmen or we
call them plebes but
college freshmen better understand some
math models
we start off with different models
and we're focused at first on something
called a difference equation
which is this idea of building a
recursion equation where the result
is based on some multiple of the
previous result
plus some other number that's kind of
our basic linear model
for a linear difference equation
and together with the initial condition
we call that a discrete dynamical system
and we start with a single equation for
the start of our course and then we
build to
systems of those recursion equations but
in order to be able to
describe and visualize and understand
what's going on with those systems of
recursion equations we need some matrix
algebra
and so we have a small section on vector
operations and matrix operations before
we
come back to the systems of recursion
equations
and so these are some of the things that
we discuss
in that class and uh that i've tried to
visualize through these forms
so i start off with just a little bit of
background i won't go too much
into the details of a linear discrete
dynamical system so you start
with a recursion equation that we often
call p sub n
and we say that given an initial
condition where
n often starts at zero we can model the
growth and decay or oscillation
of certain situations and use those to
model everything from
the balance of a bank account to how
much you owe on a loan to the population
of a particular species in an
area to the number of people who share
or have received
or recognized a certain message or idea
and you can begin to the number of
customers so
with a wolfram form
uh you can look at the wolfram language
documentation but there are a couple of
distinctions
you can run forms inside of a notebook
and
then you can also deploy those forms to
the cloud
when you use cloud deploy the cloud
deploy function in order to deploy to
the cloud
then you've increased the capability for
your colleagues or your students to be
able to use the form that you've created
and so when i'm initially trying to tell
a story that's very important because
if i can get a visual connection for you
to understand what the output might look
like
then you're that much more willing to
stick around for hey how did he get to
that solution
or how did she come to this conclusion
well
we can then name those form pages or
those forms
a particular object name and then just
run the cloud deploy function
on that object so here what i've done is
created a linear dds
in a form page i should say that the
distinction between a form and a form
page is just with the form function
you create the form and when you deploy
it to
uh the cloud it goes on a website where
the person can
input the values into the form that
you've created
but then when they click ok the result
appears but they can't
see anymore what they put into the form
using form page i found is more
productive for my students because they
can look at the top of the web browser
that i provided
after i've cloud deployed a particular
form
and they can see the inputs but then
they can also see the output
now within the form page function
uh or the form function there's
basically two big pieces
that are wrapped inside of the form
function the first part
is where you define all of the different
inputs
that you're going to ask the person to
provide
and that's what you see here i provided
an opportunity for them to describe now
you can just put the name of the thing i
could have just said d
but by by providing a description like d
is the parameter for the fixed amount of
the arithmetic change to the recursion
equation
or this is the amount that i want to add
to whatever i had before
and then tell wolfram language what kind
of
input you're expecting then you can
begin to
develop all of the inputs that you want
them to provide now
you could choose to allow them to select
colors on plots or you could provide the
distinct color in the form
it depends on what your use case is but
then after you come to the first part of
the form
there's a comma that comes outside of
all the curve brackets
and the second part is your output and
so here my output was a column
of uh different frames that provide
certain computations
based on the inputs and the inputs of
the form
are those things that you see with the
hashtag elements in front of them so i
ask them to provide a d value i ask them
to provide an a value
um and then i provide different things
in the output
uh some of them are just feeding back
what they provided so they remember
better what uh what the particular
situation was that they started from
and some of them are calculations like
what's the equilibrium value of this
system
if we started at this value an
equilibrium value then we would stay
there forever
if we start anywhere else we're either
going to get closer to or farther away
from those equilibrium values
but being able to visualize that better
enables them to understand what happens
when i change a
what happens when i change d and if they
can change those values in the form
then you're able to uh convey that
concept more powerfully i believe so
this basic linear recursion equation the
output is equal to some number
a times the previous output plus d and
then you can also at the end under the
appearance rules
you could just leave this blank or you
can provide a title and a description
that's what i've done here and so then
once you run that in your notebook
something like this appears and so then
you can see that i provided you with the
opportunity to input all of these values
and then when you're done you select the
color and you pick
the appropriate okay to submit that
now once you've provided all that
information
here's an example so in this example i
provided the a value was 2. so i'm going
to take the previous output
so let's say and this may not be the
most appropriate let's say p sub n
represented the number
of wolfram language users so this is
probably uh many many years ago when
um when dr wolfram was first developing
wolfram language but
maybe at some point uh you started with
zero users
but then each time you double the number
of users that you had the week before
if n represented weeks or maybe it
represented months whatever you've
decided to define
the iteration but you take the number of
wolfram language users in the previous
iteration
multiply it by two because i've set a
equal to two
add a d value of four additional users
um separate from the doubling maybe the
two was
people talking to other people but then
people that had never talked to people
who use wolfram
there were four of them each iteration
that also just somehow found out about
it
so in that case then what we can do is
look at okay well if i ran this for n
iterations where n equals 13 and i
wanted to know how many iterations would
i need to run before there were 512
users
then i can put that information in
select the color of my plot click ok
and i get some output that looks like
this okay
the equilibrium value is negative four
so that doesn't have any practical sense
in this particular situation i guess if
i had started with negative four users
if that was possible
then we would never uh spread the the
word about the language but
if i start with zero and then i add
4 and multiply by 2 i can put the output
in a table
that that gets rendered within the form
and you can run this
on any device that has a web browser
enabled because you've deployed it to
the cloud
and so then you can also choose whether
you want to make it public or private if
you keep it private then you
have to log in with your own ideas if
you your own wolfram id
if you make it public in terms of the
permission then you can share it with
everyone including your students or your
colleagues
i should say that when you run forms in
the cloud there is a cloud service
credit uh
cost associated with some of that and so
you just need to be cognizant of that
but when you run the forms on your
notebook you can share it internally
and that's something you have to figure
out for yourself but here's the output
and we see that over time the number of
wolfram language users would continue to
grow and grow
um and then uh you could also use this
to represent
a lot of other things uh
depending upon what you're trying to
model within the real world but then how
do you share that
so since i save this as an object called
linear dds
i can then cloud deploy it if i've
deployed it before
to a particular object and i want to
update that and i haven't given it a
human-friendly name then i want to make
sure that whatever i name that object
i put inside of here inside of cloud
deploy and then
it will write over that previous object
with the update
and then if you set the permissions to
public then anyone
can go in there and can input into your
form
now this is valuable for my students who
may want to visualize a linear dds on
their phone
but it could be valuable for colleagues
or
for customers depending upon your use
case one of the last things you can also
do within wolfram language
i'll talk about is barcode image now you
can create lots of different barcode
images but if you set
one of the options to qr code and you
take this previous output
of the web url as your input
and create a qr code if you wanted to
assuming your screen resolution is high
enough right now
you could point your phone at this
screen on the qr code if you open up the
camera application
and you would get a notification or an
option that would if you click on it
redirect you
to the form that allows you to produce
this linear dds
and i did this with a student last week
who was just slow to
uh to open and download the uh the
notebook that i had provided
via one of our other uh email and other
communication techniques but when
i put the the image on the screen and he
opened up his phone uh and it was just
instantly right there well once i've
engaged you with the
form you're that much more likely to
actually put some information into it
and then get some value out of it so
i'll go through a couple more examples
before i open up for questions but
um the form or the uh
the structure is similar so you could
use this to build a form
that visualizes network flow so this is
one of the topics that we talk about
in some of our matrix applications
besides systems of recursion equations
and so i've created a form that allows
the user to input
a bunch of different information about
their particular flow network
where you have um nodes that represent
certain spots along the network
and you could be pushing things through
them they could be 30 messages in this
example or it could be 30 packages
or it could be 30 people this could be a
transportation network
so there's a lot of different things
that you can do with this form i can
change the name of my plot
i have it set up so that you provide an
edge list
and then it produces the graph
associated with it of that network
and you can add the weights in but you
could create a similar form that took an
adjacency matrix
in order to convey the network and what
you see here is these are unknowns
i've put in strings and then this allows
a cadet to look at a particular
uh system and say okay well if there's
30 going in
there better be 30 coming out but i
haven't been given any more information
yet to say what these other values might
be so i'd have to provide them with more
information if i wanted a specific
solution
all right some of the other concepts
related to vectors
are how do we add and subtract vectors i
should say that some of my cadets have a
lot of background experience in math in
high school
many do not and so they may have had
some exposure they definitely had some
exposure to algebra geometry to
trigonometry but not everybody's had
calculus and certainly
many people have not seen vectors and
matrices so we start off with addition
and subtraction
but adding and subtracting numbers isn't
nearly as exciting
uh as at least for a lot of people
as adding and subtracting um objects or
manipulating objects
and so we talk about how a vector
uh can be a list of numbers that has a
certain dimension to it
and um represents uh
a lot of potential things from the real
world but it has a magnitude and a
direction
okay well if i can show you something
that actually has a magnitude in a
direction
and then if i use color to help to
distinguish between what i'm adding to
what
then you're that much more likely to
understand visually at least what's
going on in two dimensions
and so then when we start adding things
in four or five dimensions
uh with vectors then you're a little bit
more likely to have some appreciation of
what's going on
and so here this form takes two vectors
uh
that you provide in this case the vector
0 3 and the vector 4
0 with the standard basis vectors and
when we add them together
it produces this purple vector so then i
can talk about to a student
who can see on their phone with a
barcode image or click the link
if they're over a video chat with me
about how we're adding the tip of the
red vector and taking the tail of the
blue vector and putting it there and the
result is this purple vector
and then hey this is the magnitude but
this wasn't magic this was wolfram
language in mathematica
that i had to provide in the previous
part of the form
the formula that calculated this five or
i had to provide the angle
now depending upon your purpose within
math class you may decide to
gloss over uh the particulars of a
partic of a specific formula
or you may decide to go into more depth
and detail about that formula because
you think it's important
but the nice thing is is the form allows
you the flexibility to decide how much
detail you want to go into describing
particular concepts
okay uh i want to briefly mention
another topic
we talk about matrix operations and so i
built a form that has similar types of
setup in terms of first you provide the
information
and this code is posted in the notebook
that is on the pathable site
if you are logged in so you can look
under the files tab
and download this for yourself if you
desire but
there's the inputs and then as you go
further down
you're provided with uh the opportunity
to see what the outputs are
now what it asks for is a transformation
matrix
a and then the vector that you wanted to
start with
x and that's the way i'm trying to
describe it to my students and then i
say hey
you picked the color and they say okay
sir we'd like to take an orange vector
and turn it into a blue vector
okay and i say well the orange vector is
the vector that goes three units in the
x direction
and four units in the y direction now
what's going to happen when we multiply
it by this transformation matrix where
the first row is 2
3 the second row is 1 2. well
if we run the computation
we see that the orange vector uh gets
pushed a little bit
uh down into the right but it also gets
a lot longer and then we can have a
conversation about what it was we were
trying to represent
whether 3 4 was a particular pixel on
the
screen that you might be staring at and
i took the color of the little square
that was at the tip of the position
vector that's the orange
and i moved it because of a
transformation that i wanted to do with
image
computation on images and i moved it
over to the spot that's now where the
tip of the blue vector is and so
whatever color was on the tip of the
orange is now at the tip of the blue
after this transformation matrix a
or we can talk about rotation matrices
and then they can see it
and through repetition of changing the
values of the matrix a
or the vector x they begin to more
easily
inculcate the relationship between the
input and the output
which is one of the goals that we're
trying to do in terms of being able to
solve additional problems
all right we also fit functions to data
in the last part of our course on
modeling
and so there are some built-in functions
that definitely have a lot of use
from the wolfram language but sometimes
we want to start by
reminding people what these functions
look like and
then discussing okay well what do i
change in this parabola
this power function and that makes it a
parabola
or what do i change that causes it to
get shifted to the side horizontally
what number did i change in order to get
it to shift vertically
and so that's what this form was
designed to do
it takes an input that corresponds to
this form of
a power function where i'm taking x and
raising it to a power b
multiplying by a adding a vertical shift
d
and then i've also provided the
opportunity for them to adjust the
x plots now could you do all of this in
wolfram language by studying the plot
command
absolutely but if i want to get them
from the start then
the form allows me to do that especially
if i've deployed it to the cloud
because they can pull it up on their
phone when maybe they're moving they got
10 minutes between a couple of classes
and they know they need to do a little
bit more prep before we talk about this
in the next class
they have the flexibility with the cloud
deploy all right
now that i've talked a little bit about
some of the things that you could do
with forms i want to highlight just
quickly
what some of the output that you may
choose to use or other techniques
that aren't necessarily the form
themselves so something that i did
because computation is not just about
mathematics but it applies to
computational thinking a lot of
different disciplines
is this is kind of an extension of the
computational photography
but hey we could build a pdf slide of
some of the plots that we created with
our math
and wouldn't it be nice if you were
trying to create a bunch of different
example problems
if you had already built kind of the
structure of your slide and then you
were just able to provide
the specific computation for maybe even
randomly generated vector of
problems to solve and this might provide
you with that ability
so what i first did was uh define a
function
in wolfram language that takes a plot uh
some text that i want to put in the left
column of the slide
and a title so i put the plot on the
right hand side and then you'll notice
that this is just a nested
um image composition so the image
compose function
and i have provided a slide for kind of
a standard west point teaching slide but
you could provide your own
slide as an image inside of the function
that you create
save that function run it and then
create your input so here i did a
linear dds that involved two percent
interest so i take the previous amount
multiply it by one plus two percent or
1.02
and then i assume that the person puts
90 into their account each month and
they started with 25
i ran that and then using the table
command got a bunch of
outputs for after so many n iterations
what's the difference between the
previous iteration and this one
and what's the actual current output of
the account and then i put that into
some text uh that i turned into an image
but you don't have to it's your choice
then i built the plot what does this
look like in terms of the output of that
table
using the list plot command then once i
had my plot i put them together into the
slide by just running
my slide function with the input of the
slide
plot in the text table and the title
that i put in there
you could put whatever text you wanted
in here and then
you can quickly create your slide and
export it as a pdf or any other image
format
finally i didn't do this because we have
a learning management system
uh software available to us that we're
encouraged to use
but if i was working remotely with
students and i didn't have the advantage
of some of those
resources you could also use wolfram
language
and the cloud deploy to deploy a
notebook that was styled like a web page
to the cloud cloud deploy the notebook
now you can use the cloud deploy or
cloud publish function
within a wolfram notebook or you can if
you're working
in mathematica on the desktop version
click on the file menu and then come
down to the
publish to cloud and it will provide you
with the url for the place that you
published it to so you got some
flexibility there
an example that i provide here is
at this particular site again if you
were to point your camera
at this qr code it would redirect you
to this webpage that has a wolfram
notebook with some
hyperlinks inside of it and some
additional text
and an image that i created of a map
using some of the newer geographic
functions
um with geographic plots
anyhow uh my basic point is that you can
use cloud deploy
um you can use cloud publish in order to
better share your ideas with your
students
in a remote learning environment but
also with your colleagues
and so an example of doing that within
the
learning management system that we use i
was able to
use the embed code function that's built
into wolfram alpha and it provides me
with the
html language that i can just copy into
one of the items in our learning
management system
and then it automatically imports my
form
so this form was designed in order to
allow students to
visualize what a 3d plane was based on a
parametric equation
i'll take whatever questions we have
with the remaining five minutes or so
thank you very much for your time and
attention
there are a couple of questions on the
path of chat if you wanted to take a
quick peek at that
ah yes okay um
so yes the highlight about uh form
versus form page so
that's helpful in terms of again uh
depending upon your user
and what they might be interested in the
form page allows you to see your output
and input on the same side
uh the same site and
um yes so comment about cloud publish
i've only used the cloud publish uh once
but that's a very good note
and um i might be using that more often
because most of the stuff that i do is
stuff that i'm just as happy to share
with the rest of the world as i do with
my cadets
although i think it's mostly the cadets
that are interested how much do we
discuss wolfram language syntaxes
in the class before introducing form
pages so i'll say uh that
first i'm one of a few people that
actually use the forms and form pages
in terms of sharing the wolfram language
with my students a lot of other
colleagues
everyone uses mathematica and the
wolfram language itself
and the syntax of some of the basic
functions um
is kind of the introduction to our
uh discussion about matrices so it's
kind of one of those things where
historically
the basic recursion equation when it's
just by itself
we've been able to describe the students
pretty well in excel
uh but i use it as an opportunity to
start
with the table command and show some of
those recursion equations in mathematica
because i feel like the earlier that i
start exposing them to some of the
wolfram language
the less of a learning curve it is when
we actually
need it more when we start working with
matrices
and so we're fortunate enough that some
instructors
choose to use the pallets a lot of the
time in order to
avoid delving too much into the
particulars of hey there's a curly
bracket here and a square bracket here
but for um it's kind of an instructor
decision i guess is
though is the way that we've handled it
but students have the ability to use
mathematica on certain assessments uh
not on others depending upon
what it is that we're trying to assess
and so the students who are more
comfortable
the way i described it to some of my
students last week was how would you
like to have 10 less of minutes
on our next exam and nobody raised their
hand
i said well you know if you
don't take the time to learn a few of
these basic commands or at least get
familiar with the documentation so that
you can run them
even if you can do some of this by hand
it's going to take you a little bit
longer
because we designed the exam with the
assumption that you knew how to use
some things in mathematica in order to
uh to solve this particular type of
problem
and so that that gets some people's uh
attention
um how often does students ask about the
code behind the scene
uh so that's the danger of i think the
form is
the oversimplification and that okay
it's like magic we um
we got this solution but we don't
necessarily
uh know where it came from and the nice
thing about the appendix in our textbook
is that
some of the previous instructors have
provided
more detailed examples of some of the
code i just like to direct my students
because a lot of times it's hard to get
them back into the textbook but
use the question question mark and then
the name of the function that you're
looking for and the built-in
documentation
will pop up with some examples if you're
using the desktop version and you can go
through those examples and get more
familiar with the syntax
so we kind of leave it as an individual
choice for these students
how detailed they want to get with it
but
the those who delve in a little bit more
find themselves with a few extra minutes
to
go back and check their answers on
certain assessments and they find
themselves with a slightly better
polished product
if they've used wolfram language to help
produce a report for a project
um high school student
i found your talk is a good summary
thanks thank you as well
uh i is there enough
informal wolfram language special
interest group among professors and
students at service academies
i am uh i'm not sure about that
um i i don't believe so formally i know
uh from time to time there are
um there are
communications between some of the
service academies and uh there's a
journal
that um professors and students um
can uh submit articles to from the
different service academies as well uh
but beyond that um i don't think there
is much
of a uh cross discussion i guess i
should say that i know there was at
least
some amount of cross discussion uh
particularly about the topic of
the licensing contract but i was not
involved with any of the particulars i
just know that one of the considerations
is making sure that we renew our license
each year
anyhow i appreciate everyone's time and
consideration and
all the uh the great questions i hope i
was able to address them
and thank you very much for your time i
think i'm out of time
we can go a little longer if there are
any questions but if there aren't any
others we can uh we can end the session
um
yeah i guess uh just to follow up on the
uh
the bit about uh the code behind the
scene i found a variety of different
students so i had one student
uh last semester who was really into
some of the particulars of uh using
mathematica and wolfram language not
just in his class
uh for um the calculus course he was
taking but also to
better describe some of the uh the
solutions that he was trying to get to
in some of his other classes and so he
wanted to do things with animation and
videos
so he was very willing to delve into the
details of some of the code
most of my students are kind of content
once you show them row reduce on an
augmented matrix to just kind of say oh
okay this is the
function that i use for this particular
situation this is the tool
and now i just need to make sure i know
how to put a matrix in
but i found that if you um show people a
couple of different examples that
we get kind of a mix and then you can
also start to tell
what some people's particular academic
interests might be
and those who are more into some of the
engineering and sciences
are are tend to be the ones that want to
go ahead and revise some of the code
themselves because they weren't
satisfied with the output
and that's what i got thank you very
much for your time
i hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference
you